you know who's not laughing everyone
involved in the Vanderpump Rules
cheating scandal the last thing I was
expecting was to be judged on like
getting drunk and having fun I've been a
wreck but I'm trying to put on a brave
face that's newly single Ariana Maddox
just back from a Mexican getaway and
breaking her silence saying to call her
quote devastated and broken is an
understatement her post last night comes
exactly two weeks after she discovered
that her partner of nine years Tom
Sandoval was secretly hooking up with
co-star Raquel Levis for months Raquel
now is Wild and Free I'm focusing more
on myself Ariana wrapped up her post
with what felt like a warning quote what
doesn't kill me better run are you
having anxiety panic attack get out
Raquel wasn't running but in last
night's episode shot pre-scandle in late
Summer she did break down we did not
re-edit tonight's episode of Vanderpump
Rules it was as it happened and yep Andy
Cohen called it looking back with the
cheating scandal in mind here's some
moments we're side eyeing today I'm
starting to see a pattern in Raquel it
seems that she's only interested in men
that her friends are either married to
or interested in and that is a big red
flag for me then the irony of this
people were calling you a mistress why
do you think that is he was married
oh my God hey check out Sandoval's look
when Raquel crashes the boys night out
and gives him a hug there's speculation
this was the night their Affair actually
started E.T has learned the Vanderpump
reunion is set to take next Thursday but
it's complicated by the fact that Raquel
has filed a restraining order against
co-star Sheena Shea Sheena Is denying
Raquel's claim that she punched her and
there's more breaking Bravo news don't
act like our marriage was awesome
Juan Dixon from Real Housewives of
Potomac has reportedly been fired from
his job as head basketball coach at
Coppin State University Juan was named
in a sexual assault lawsuit involving a
member of his coaching staff during the
season seven reunion his wife Robin came
to his defense the wrongdoings that they
are saying that Wanda did not happen and
it's just unfortunate that Juan was kind
of used as click bait to really push the
story
foreign